VANESSA STARK: Hi.
Vanessa here.
I'm a marketer here at Google,
for Google Cloud Platform.
ALEXANDER ZAMUDIO: And
hi from me, Alexander.
I'm on the Google
Cloud Sales team.
On this episode, we'll
look at Cloud Bigtable,
the same database that powers
many of Google's core services,
including search,
analytics, maps, and Gmail.
VANESSA STARK: We'll also
run through a quick demo
of the self-paced lab, where
we'll use a command line
utility to connect a
Cloud Bigtable instance,
and read and write
data in a table.
Don't forget, you can also apply
what you've learned here today
with a $300 free trial
credit to use on GCP.
So let's get started.
So let's look at some of the
key features of Bigtable.
Because Bigtable offers high
performance under high load,
large apps and workflows are
faster, more reliable, and more
efficient running on Bigtable.
ALEXANDER ZAMUDIO: Bigtable is
ideal for storing large amounts
of data with very low latency.
Databases can automatically
and seamlessly
scale to billions of rows
and thousands of columns,
allowing you to store
petabytes of data.
Plus, you only pay for the
amount of storage you use.
- Because Bigtable is a
fully managed service,
you don't need to worry
about configuring and tuning
your database for
performance or scalability.
We'll also create
backups of your data
to protect against
catastrophic events
and allow for disaster recovery.
ALEXANDER ZAMUDIO:
Bigtable's offered
through the same open
source industry standard API
as HBase, the native database
by the Apache Hadoop project.
The HBase compatible
interface provided by Bigtable
supports movement
of applications
between HBase and Bigtable.
VANESSA STARK: As Bigtable
as part of the GCP ecosystem,
it can interact
with other services
and third-party clients.
In terms of security,
all data in Bigtable
is encrypted both
in-flight and at rest,
while access to Bigtable
data is easily controlled
through IAM permissions.
ALEXANDER ZAMUDIO:
In this hands-on lab,
you'll use the CBT
command line utility
to connect to a Cloud
Bigtable instance,
and read and write
data in a table.
VANESSA STARK: You
can check out the link
to start the QuickLab here.
You will need to set aside
about 30 minutes to complete it.
ALEXANDER ZAMUDIO:
So far in the lab,
we've created a Cloud Bigtable
instance and configured CBT
to use your project in
the instance by modifying
the .cbtrc File.
We create a table My-Table.
We list the tables to
verify My-Table was created.
We add a column,
Family Name, CF1.
We list the column families
to verify CF1 was created.
We put the value,
test-value, in row R1,
using the column family CF1
and the column qualifier C1.
We read the data
added to the table.
VANESSA STARK: We hope
you enjoyed this episode.
Please feel free to
share your experiences
or ideas of using Bigtable.
It's always good
to hear from you.
ALEXANDER ZAMUDIO: If you
haven't already done so,
check out this
link where you can
apply what you've learned
using a $300 free trial
credit on Google Cloud Platform.
VANESSA STARK: All of our
additional training resources
are linked below.
Thanks again for watching,
and see you soon.